de quoi on parle on parle de ça enfin on
parle plutôt de cet ordinateur la lah
celui-là mais son nom il écrit là c'est
le honor magic gook view 14 et le honor
magic boucle de 14 il est intéressant
parce que ça ordinateur qui est je
trouve premium très premium au niveau du
design au niveau des finitions en or
havas ont bien bossé alors souvenez vous
souvenez vous c'est quand je suis à
passer l'année dernière c'était ya deux
ans karine vernière taille dernière je
crois au nord avait sorti un magic book
14 ayant souhaité une version
professionnelle que je vous avais
présenté ans que j'étais à berlin bref
on bouge en valais c'est sympa et là ils
reviennent avec ce produit qui aussi
très très chouette on a un écran 3 demi
plein de jolies finition je vais vous
montrer j'ai à vous expliquer alors on
laisse un ordinateur je vous le dis tout
de suite front biais comme ça pas vous
le savez on est orientée sur la
productivité clairement alors ça veut
pas dire ne pas regarder de films avec
ça veut pas dire pas utilisé pour de la
productivité familial ça peut être les
familiales et professionnelles on a un
écran je vous dirais qu'un ratio de 3 2
me qui on fera un peu plus par rapport à
1 16 9e ont ainsi 7 on a pas mal de
choses à l'intérieur qui font que cette
machine est intéressante elle est
polyvalente on peut aussi brancher un
moniteur 8e bref vous allez tout savoir
et surtout non il n'est pas dans le bon
sens il est en ce sens là bah oui parce
que comme ça quand vous êtes en face et
je l'ouvré bien vous voyez la marque oui
vous pouvez la lire sympa pour les gens
qui sont en france et c'est aujourd'hui
une vidéo qui réalisé en partenariat
avec honor aux normes a demandé de
parler de son nouvel ordinateur et comme
j'avais beaucoup aimé les magic bout des
générations précédentes ont fait un
plaisir on va découvrir ensemble ce
magic book review 14
regardez c'est chouette j'aime beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup le design
c'est extrêmement premium alors ici
c'est du space grèce et le nom c'est le
nom de la cool c'est tout optimisé à
gratter on a vraiment les haut parleurs
qui sont planqués sur le côté c'est très
très très très bien fichu on a très peu
de places de perdues on track pack qui
est quand même grand par rapport à la
surface totale qu'on a ici on a des
touches qui sont vraiment bien fait je
vais vous détailler l'histoire du club
dans quelques instants mais vraiment
trans côté design je trouve que au nord
a vraiment bien bossé au moment où tout
est extrêmement premium matériaux qui
sont très solides pour autant c'est une
machine qui est pas très lourd on est
dans les standards qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui sur des ordinateurs
portables on est sur un kilo 48 je
trouve relativement aussi à ses fins
surtout au niveau de la vamp la regarder
au niveau de l'avant is it c'est très
standard par rapport à toi pour trouver
sur le marché en terme de forme en
termes de design et pour autant je
prouve une fois de plus et j'ai vraiment
apprécié parce que c'est un truc qui est
vraiment vraiment important les
finitions sont super super super super
super jolie et très très joli travail de
honor là dessus lorsque je viens
d'ouvrir au queen deux lots du fameux
tronche il ouvrit les verrous facilement
puis un deuxième point qui est aussi
très intéressant à regarder je referme
le lourd vous allez voir vous avez un
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui est
situé juste là vous posez votre doigt
idée l'hérault et vous arrivez
directement sa voix tout mine devait
donc ça c'est bien ça dans windows 11
alors windows
on revient un petit peu dessus parce
qu'on en a déjà parlé c'est plutôt bien
j'ai fait une vidéo dédiée sur windows
on si vous l'avez pas vu aller la voir
parce que l'app la nouveauté c'est très
très cool vous avez notamment ce petit
menu au centre ça c'est super on
reconnaît très très facilement comme ça
vous allez avoir de toutes vos
applications au claj appuyé ailleurs
est-ce qu'on a un écran tactile vous
l'avez vu vous voulez toutes vos
applications qui sont situées juste ici
pas un bref aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil à la vidéo que j'ai fait sur
windows comme ça vous saurez tout ça
c'est très très cool or vous le voyez
ici vous avez un écran qui est tactile
donc ça c'est un point qui est vachement
cool donc ça ne très très bien très
réactif ça marche super bien vous avez
si un grand écran c'est du 2,5 à 2520
par 1680 pixels dalle lcd bien
évidemment la techno c'est du un tps un
écran 14 2,2 pouces vous avez en tout
cas intéressant sur cet écran c'est que
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement de
90 heures il faut passer dessus pour
passer dessus c'est la touche fn et air
aux résolutions vous switchez hop là
regardez là je suis en 90 hertz fn et m
et j'ai passé en 60 hertz alors bien
évidemment le 90 fière de venir prendre
un peu plus d'énergie va consommer
davantage que le 60 hertz si vous ne
jouez pas des jeux si vous n'avez pas
besoin de fuite c'est sûr de la
navigation est bien resté sur du 60
hertz si vous sentez que vous avez une
envie de gaming vous avez besoin de
performances bien vous avez deux
possibilités la première c'est
effectivement fntr vous changez votre
résolution vous faites aussi fn et paix
ça va changer ça vous passez en mode
performance et ça va venir tartine
davantage regarder fait pareil fn et
ppri est activée il faut qu'il soit
branché sur le secteur avait d'accord
donc si vous voulez un mode performance
vous le branchez alors on va faire tout
de suite qu'il est qu'aucun suis là je
vous jure alors je le prends je le
branche alors pour brancher pour montrer
la connectique comme quoi vous le verrez
aussi rapidement vous venez le recharger
directement en usb cicr vous avez deux
ports usb c'est vous avez un premier
port usb c'est vous le voyez tout
indicateur de charge vous venez de
charge est ici c'est un port usb c'est
thunderball 4 et vous en avez un
deuxième usb c'est qui lui n'est pas
sommes dans un bol cas donc vous avez un
seul thunderball 4 vous venez leur
charge et vous avez une petite prise
jack ici sur le côté et vous avez ici de
l'usb à 3.2 et qui est ici pardon et
vous avez un hdmi quais situés juste là
où ça c'est cool alors on vient de
recharger avec un bloc de charge 60 100
watts et standard ce bloc de charge 65
mois d'août permettra également de venir
recharger votre smartphone pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs ici j'ai un honneur 50 on
peut venir les faire communiquer tous
les deux un truc dans quelques instants
alors je le branche je le mets ici ouais
parce qu'en fait il va considérer que le
mode performance à venir prendre plus
d'énergie et donc si vous voulez aller
plus loin sur des party games et vous
avez besoin de ressources davantage au
niveau de votre décale bien il veut
qu'il soit branché pourquoi pas alors on
déverrouille sic et empreintes digitales
sommes à chaud comme monsieur gros et la
fntp et voyez je passe en mode
performance mode équilibré donc j'ai
choix entre deux mois donc voyez lorsque
je veux venir jouer un jeu alors je vais
pas et comme un dingue hein parce qu'ici
je suis sûr en intel core i7 c'est la
onzième génération la référence ou du
tout de suite c'est un 11390 h comme ça
vous saurez tout on est certifié intel
et vaut ici donc vraiment très très très
belle machine je vais pouvoir jouer à
des jeux mais j'ai pas prendre les jeux
les plus gourmands mais je peux quand
même bien faire tourner des jeux dessus
donc lorsque je de la fluidité que je
veux vraiment être peinard 90 herth
performance est là sa tartine et lorsque
je suis dans le mode productivité je
descends 60 hertz je passe en mode
équilibré et j'ai une machine qui
rateraient bien vous voyez c'est une
machine qui en fait assez polyvalente on
va s'adresser aux gamers cdc à la
productivité pourra me dire faire pas
mal de petites choses avec pudeur faire
aussi un peu de montage si on le
souhaite mais on va rester quand même
assez limités en termes de terre fille
si en plus vous avez 16 giga de ram vous
avez une seule confie celle giga de ram
c'est la pellinière 4x et puis vous avez
500 12 giga de stockage et uniquement en
ssd donc ça fera la ferme et réfléchie
c'est vraiment à vous ce que vous voulez
en faire je vous dis productivité
familiale productivité professionnels du
divertissement bien évidemment du gaming
attention à sa configuration vérifie que
ça passe bien sur votre bécane par
rapport à vos jeux par rapport à vos
besoins c'est une machine qui est quand
même très polyvalente au niveau
graphique on n'a pas un truc de fou hein
c'est pour ça qu'en terme de gaming on
va pas aller très très loin c'est une
intel irie 6e graphics donc c'est une
carte dédiée on va pas avoir ici de
nvidia on va pas avoir autre chose donc
bon on va rester quand même sur un truc
un peu basique un truc qui est
intéressant et je pas si vous en rendrez
compte on a un refroidissement thermique
forcément si vous allez venir à faire
tourner un peu la machine mais c'est
assez silencieux garder une petite
soufflerie on est sur du 22 décibels
nous allons sonore et c'est vrai que
c'est pas très très bruyant donc ça
c'est assez sympa au tchad et à savoir
sur l'écran ici vous avez plein vol
débranche et il est fou le chat ça
suffira largement vous avez en plus et
ce au niveau de votre écran plus d'un
milliard de couleurs et vous avez une
gamme de couleurs 100% srgb on peut
venir faire du travail de retouche photo
du lightroom photoshop dessus mais on va
être aussi a ses limites et donc une
fois de plus on peut faire un peu de
retouches mais c'est pas ici qu'on va
aller le plus loin de par l'écran et de
par la performance tout en sachant qu'en
plus ici vous avez un écran qui est
certifié lutter contre la lumière bleue
et qui est certifié également anti
scintillement tout ça ce sont des
certifications qui sont faites par tüv
rheinland coller ces problèmes en oeuvre
island a fait un petit moment qu'on en
parle donc vous ne devriez pas souffrir
de fatigue oculaire après plusieurs
heures de travail sur cette bécane et
puisqu'on parle de plusieurs heures de
travail est bon on peut y arriver alors
on nous annonce jusqu'à 11 heures à peu
près 11 heures niveau de la productivité
et jusqu'à 15 heures en visionnage de
films en 1080p alors l'idée c'est pas
regarder des films pendant quinze jours
de suite mais pour donner un petit peu
une idée on va tabler sur 9e en 10
heures en travaillons dessus ça va
dépendre une fois de plus si vous êtes
sur un mode performance ou pas un mode
performance mois performance va
forcément réduire drastiquement
l'autonomie mais on va se dire ah les 9
10 heures on peut travailler son
problème et après vous le recharger
rapidement et votre blog de charge 65
watts or à peu près 14 15 minutes de
charge est reparti pour deux heures et
demi donc ça va et parce qu'ici vous
avez une batterie de 60 watts heure et
honore nos amis si une double caméra
grand angle de 5 mégapixels l'idée c'est
lorsque vous êtes en concurrence avec du
monde à côté de vous bien et pouvoir
venir les capter facilement ça servira
pour la visio confessionnelle mais
également pour les discussions en
famille alors après il ya nos trucs
avoir acquis intéressant garder la
justice si vous avez une petite touche
sur f8 vous faites un ptit fn et 8 et
vous venez d activer votre caméra donc
y'a un côté ici qui est assez sympa en
termes de confidentialité voyez tac je
la remets je l'enlève je la remets je
l'enlève bail avec le son vous le rende
et muet ou désactiver tous les micros là
vous verrez active donc un tout qui est
intéressant vraiment sûr de la
confidentialité s'ils défendent un peu
parano et qu'on n'a pas envie il est
filmé et bien on vienne à désactiver
facilement et là on est peinard
maintenant je voudrais vous parler un
petit peu de l'expérience avec le
trackpad or ce tract pas que je trouve
vraiment pas mal c'est sympa à utiliser
assez bien fichue en terme de navigation
ça conviendra facilement et puis on a un
clavier qui est très sympa que la vie
qui est bien évidemment rétro éclairé
sans s'en doutera course de frappe qui
est très bonne très bon confort pour
venir travailler et écrire faire ce
qu'on veut donc ça c'est cool aussi et
c'est bien évidemment on a du wifi s'ils
sont un indice de réparabilité de 7,2
sur dix il ya tout ce dont on n'a pas
parlé qui est extrêmement importante
c'est un des gros points forts de cette
machine et de l'écosystème au nord et
bien c'était pouvoir faire communiquer
autre au nord cinq ans avec votre magic
book review 14 pouces comment ça se
passait assez simple vous prenez votre
smartphone vous le posez au niveau de
votre ipad vous avez du nfc gardais et
lui va venir communiqué alors le petit
bruit il se lance sur la machine et là
ça vous ouvre une communication multi
screen alors la communication multi
screen qu'est ce qui se passe et les
regarde et je vous mets le téléphone à
côté vous venez bouger sur votre
téléphone ça bouge directement ici donc
l'idée c'est pas juste d'avoir un côté
mirroring que ce soit rigolo grisonne et
j'arrive à piloter mon téléphone de la
fait la même chose sur votre ordinateur
le bouger pouvait venir naviguer
directement et ruquier pratique c'est
effectivement et bien on peut venir
faire des copier coller je suis en train
de taper un texte dans word et bien je
peux le coller directement dans mon
smartphone pareil je peux envoyer des
sms que j'ai tapé directement grâce à
mon clavier à des jeux mais l'a par
exemple qui démarre une discussion là je
mets là j'ai envoyé un sms je mets un
petit coucou toi je peux l'envoyer bref
je peux taper des conversations whatsapp
directement depuis mon ordinateur alors
on peut le faire avec moi de sap web si
on veut et si on veut pas s'embêter
taper des sms et de faire directement
depuis son ordinateur on peut le faire
on peut également passer des appels
depuis son ordinateur via son téléphone
on peut faire du partage de connexion
extrêmement facilement depuis son
téléphone vers son ordinateur on peut
faire du copier coller on peut partager
des photos des vidéos faire des
glisser-déposer bref c'est extrêmement
pratique et c'est toute cette sonde
écosystème qui est extrêmement
importante et qui apporte en termes
d'usagé sont faire communiquer
facilement l'ordinateur son smartphone
et bien évidemment si on va encore plus
loin en termes de réflexion avec sa
montre connecter tous les produits au
nord disponibles d'ailleurs c'est un
produit qui vous intéressent magic bout
view 14e vous ai mis un lien en bas dans
la description et c'est un ordinateur
qui coûte
il coûte de l'argent il coûte 1149 euros
50 et vous avez des offres disponibles
sur le site de au nord je vous mets un
lien en bas dans la description aller
jeter un petit coup d'oeil si vous
souhaitez vous faire plaisir à voir une
machine qui est très belle de belles
finitions en intel core i7 c'est la
onzième génération avec une bonne
autonomie avec un bel écran le fait de
pouvoir switcher en 90 ans passés en
mode performance si on a besoin on est
de la modularité on invoque la viola de
belles finitions on a du sound en bois
cate bref on a une belle machine un peu
plus 1000 euros 1149 euros 50 luce
différents packs le lien est en bas dans
la description a vous de me dire vous
comment vous le trouvez est-ce que vous
avez déjà acheté landes iniateurs de
honor est ce que vous avez un smartphone
des odeurs qu'est ce que vous avez
acheté le au nord 52 je vous ai fait une
vidéo sur le au nord 56 vous ne l'avez
pas déjà vu aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil ne fait plus le lien en bas dans
la description que je vous mettrais là
le lien je sais pas jouer aux médias
bref je mets des liens je suis comme ça
chez un mec sympa on se trouve très vite
pour continuer à parler textes sombres à
des bisous pour le soin de vous et à
bientôt des bisous ciao
[Musique]